Speaker 1: I want to start with immigration
today because we're continuing to follow the
immigration situation in the US Mexico border,
you may well know that Donald Trump's presidency
saw some horrible things happen from the standpoint
of immigration, including the scaling up of
the separation of immigrant children from
their parents, scaling up of specific types
of deportations, although deportations were
actually quite high under Barack Obama.
No progress whatsoever on some kind of permanent
status for for DACA, the Dreamer recipients,
the list goes on and on.
And we've talked about that.
And as Joe Biden's domestic policy during
his first 100 days has been widely successful,
empirically popular with the American people,
including even with many Republicans, Republicans
and right wing media have had to come up with
something that will register as a pseudo scandal
for Joe Biden and criticisms of him, other
than simply he's a socialist that might resonate
with the American people.
And one such criticism, one such area has
been immigration, despite the almost painful
double standard for us.
Right.
I mean, you know, the right doesn't understand
double standards or they're not affected by
them any more.
But despite what for us has been an almost
painful double standard of them starting to
pretend to care about the kids at the border
the day that Joe Biden becomes president,
while they said nothing about it, when Donald
Trump was president of the United States,
they have been pushing this crisis at the
border story.
And to some degree, it has worked.
The number of Americans who believe that the
immigration situation is a top issue has almost
doubled from June.
I think it was about 28 percent of Americans
believed it was an emergency situation in
June.
Now 48 percent do.
They've also included in this pseudo scandal,
the numbers of increased border crossings
excuse me, during the first part of the year.
And as we previously talked about, that's
very deceptive because there's a big seasonality
to border crossings in the first quarter of
the year, particularly in February and March.
Every year, border crossings go up.
This year in particular, we not only saw that
for seasonal reasons, but there's also been
this pent up demand from people who would
have tried to cross at sometime in 2020, and
they did not because of the pandemic movement
was just dramatically reduced during the pandemic.
So we talked about the kind of seasonality
of that and why just looking at that change
month to month doesn't really tell us everything
we need to know.
Now, there's a real new problem for Republicans
pushing this, and that's that the number of
unaccompanied migrant children that are being
held in these jail like conditions by Customs
and Border Patrol.
The number is down 84 percent in the span
of just a month.
As of Wednesday, there were nine hundred and
fifty four children remaining in these Border
Patrol facilities.
That's down from nearly 6000 on March 28th.
That's an incredible decline per official.
Speaking to CNN, the average time that kids
are now in Border Patrol custody is down to
twenty eight hours.
It was one hundred and thirty three hours
on March 28th.
That is nearly an 80 percent reduction in
how long each of these kids is spending with
Border Patrol.
Now, this may actually be part of why you've
been hearing less about this from Republicans
for the last 10 to 14 days.
It's not that they care about the facts.
They've just decided to ignore the topic because
of these numbers.
And to be fair, they've been distracted with
some other things as well.
Now, I'm going to be consistent.
How could I honestly say three minutes ago,
some of this fluctuation is seasonal and now
say this is down only because of Joe Biden.
Know that there is likely some seasonality
here, as well as to why we saw the number
of children decline in April versus March.
But part of this is because Joe Biden actually
made it a priority to resolve more of these
cases more quickly and to get the numbers
down.
Now, the big picture is that this changes
almost nothing about the urgency of finding
a permanent solution to the immigration situation.
DACA needs to be dealt with.
It's long overdue.
There needs to be a permanent solution for
those under the DACA program.
But the point here is that even the acute
numbers that Republicans are now cynically
pointing to, remember during the Trump administration,
they didn't care about these children at the
border.
The numbers Republicans are now cynically
pointing to in order to attack Joe Biden are
now looking increasingly better and better.
So how will right wing media and Republicans
react?
There's a few possibilities.
Part one is they may do what they've been
doing the last 10 to 14 days, which is they
may just stop talking about.
It reminds me of the Ebola situation in.
Fourteen leading up.
Barack Obama reelected in 2012, then we had
the campaign for the midterms of 2014 leading
up to the midterms in November of 2014, it
was day after day after day of Ebola, Ebola,
Ebola.
Obama's handling Ebola terribly.
Remember, two people died in the U.S. I think
none of those two people even contracted it
in the U.S.
It was just hammering on Ebola.
And I said at the time, not an incredibly
astute predict, didn't take much skill to
predict.
I said this is politically motivated.
After the election, there's going to be no
more talk of this.
And after the midterms, there was no more
talk of Ebola.
Contrast that with Trump saying no one's going
to talk about covid if I lose in November
and the election's over.
And of course, that was not the case because
it was a real problem actually mishandled
by Trump.
In any case, that may be one approach from
Republicans, which is now that the number
of kids at the border is down 84 percent,
just don't talk about it.
Second option is they may just lie and talk
about it as if the numbers don't exist or
aren't available.
Just continue saying the same thing they might
go with.
Unfortunately, Biden has still left almost
a thousand kids at the border facilities,
ignoring that that number is down 84 percent.
They may just be more vague and say there
are still kids being held by Joe Biden or
something.
That may be one thing.
You may see headlines like Biden Administration
Continues Child Detention Program that was
initiated by Barack Obama.
That'd be like a beautiful Fox News headline
that ignores what happened in the four years
intervening.
But truly, while knowing that this is just
one part of the immigration problem, it is
really difficult to change anything quickly
when the American federal government is involved.
It's a country of three hundred and thirty
one million people.
That's why the Biden vaccination program has
been so notable.
That's why reducing these numbers of kids
at the border by 84 percent in a month.
There's a seasonality, but it still is an
accomplishment and a legitimate one at that.
We'll see how Republicans react to it.